حسنًا ، أريد مناقشة هذا الأمر بمزيد من التفصيل
مع الدكتورة ريسينا بيسيت ،
إنها طبيبة طب الطوارئ
والمديرة الطبية في
كلية بايلور للطب ، من
الجيد رؤيتك وعطلات سعيدة ،
مرحباً ، أعياد سعيدة ، على الرغم من أنها ليست
سعيدة ، إنها مخيفة جدًا ،
أليس كذلك؟  والآن لدينا هذا الحديث عن
هذا البديل
الجديد لهذا الطمع 19. نحن نعلم الآن
أنه انتقل من المملكة المتحدة
إلى فرنسا يقول الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة فايزر إسبانيا إنه
متفائل بأن لقاح شركته
سيعمل ضده ،
هل أنت متفائل أيضًا  أنا
متفائل جدًا بأن
اللقاحات الفريدة من نوعها تتحور بطبيعتها ، وهذا
ما تم تصميمه للقيام بذلك ، فليس من
المستغرب أننا وجدنا هذا
البديل الجديد في المملكة المتحدة
في الواقع مرة أخرى في أبريل ،
كان هناك نوع مختلف من فيروس كورونا اكتشف
في
الهند والذي اعتقد الناس أنه يمكن
يحتمل أن يعيق السباق لتطوير
لقاح ولم
يثبت أن خبراء اللقاحات
وعلماء الفيروسات مثل دكتور
كيزي لا قلقون بشأن هذا
البديل الجديد وإليك
سبب اللقاح  التي تم تطويرها
حتى الآن تهاجم
عدة أماكن مختلفة على
البروتين الشائك للفيروس التاجي ،
لذا فإن التغيير في مساحة صغيرة واحدة من هذا
البروتين لن يجعل لقاحاتنا
عديمة الفائدة تمامًا ،
بل سيتطلب الكثير من
التنوع الجيني لذلك  حدث
حسنًا ، يعجبني تفاؤلك
بدءًا من يوم الاثنين في المملكة المتحدة ،
يجب أن يخضع جميع الركاب لاختبار Coven 19 السلبي في
غضون ثلاثة أيام من الصعود على متن رحلة
إلى
حاكم نيويورك الأمريكي ، وأشاد أندرو كومو
بقرار مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (cdc) لفحص الركاب
الذين يسافرون من الولايات المتحدة.
قال كومو في هذا البيان يوم
الجمعة إن المراكز الأمريكية للأمراض  أعلنت المراقبة والوقاية
عن متطلبات الاختبار الجديدة
للمسافرين ، لكن الأبحاث التي أجراها
علماء الوكالة
تظهر أن القاعدة قد يكون لها تأثير ضئيل فقط
بشأن انتشار السلالة البريطانية الجديدة من
الفيروس التاجي
وفقًا للباحثين في
فريق الاستجابة 19 coven التابع لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، الذي
اختبر قبل ثلاثة أيام من الرحلة ، قد
يقلل من خطر انتشار الفيروس بنسبة تتراوح بين
خمسة إلى تسعة في المائة فقط ،
وتختبر شركة فايزر الحديثة لمعرفة ما إذا كانت
تعمل اللقاحات ضد المتغير الجديد
الذي لم يتم اكتشافه حتى الآن
في جنوب الولايات المتحدة ،
وتكافح كاليفورنيا مع
ارتفاع عدد حالات
الاستشفاء والوفيات في مستشفى كوبيت 19 ، حيث تمر الولاية بمرحلة
قاتمة أخرى تبلغ عن أكثر
من 300
طمع جديد لليوم الثالث على التوالي
في مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس.  شخص يموت
كل 10 دقائق من تغطية
مدير الصحة العامة في المقاطعة 19 يقول
أعتقد أن الناس
لا يعتقدون أن فيروس كورونا سيحدث
لهم ويعتقدون أن الفيروس التاجي سيحدث
لعائلة أخرى
ولكن لا توجد سلامة بخلاف تلك
الإجراءات الصحية العامة التي كنا
نعظ منها  قمم الجبال
مع اقتراب عيد الميلاد نهايته ونتجه
إلى العام الجديد
يقول الخبراء أن الطريقة الأكثر أمانًا للسيل
ebrate في المنزل
مع الأشخاص الذين تعيش معهم أو عبر الإنترنت
مع الأصدقاء
والعائلة لأولئك الذين يستضيفون احتفالًا بالعام الجديد
، يقترح مركز السيطرة على الأمراض البقاء في الخارج
للحد من عدد الضيوف الذين يرتدون
أقنعة وإتاحة أقنعة إضافية
والحفاظ على الموسيقى الخلفية منخفضة
لتجنب الصراخ